what about not being healed from a
relationship and going into another
relationship should the focus be on
working on yourself until you've healed
well look i think it's not possible to
to fully heal from a past relationship
without having new relationships and it
doesn't have to be romantic
relationships we heal relationally right
because if we've had trust broken or if
we felt betrayed or if we've lost hope
how are we going to heal that on our own
like we need connection so that we can
remind ourselves and reaffirm that love
is safe that connection is safe we
really do require relationship as human
beings most of us enter into
relationships with unhealed stuff from
the past like i've not yet met a person
who doesn't have something that they
that isn't quite resolved um
painful experience or memory that might
be lingering underneath the surface or
that might be causing some hesitancy to
let go and that's just the nature of
being human and taking leaps and you
know experimenting in love
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the pretty
intense podcast thank you so much for
coming uh you're in for a treat today a
lovely delicate sweet
and important treat of shalina ayana she
is a spiritual counselor she has an
incredible account on instagram
that is called rising woman
and she just wrote a book her first book
called becoming the one i don't think
there could be probably a more important
message and lesson for everyone to
step into and embody and that's that
you're not trying to find the person
that's going to complete you you're
going to learn how to complete yourself
and you're going to become the one that
you're always seeking and it doesn't
mean that we aren't in community it
doesn't mean that we don't have helping
hands along the way it doesn't mean that
we don't
work through things with people at times
but we learn how to become secure in
ourselves so that we create secure
attachment in relationships so we talked
about just you know what does an ideal
world look like too what what would what
is dull of this
what is everything going on in the world
what is the best case scenario for that
and what would an ideal
reality look like and you know i think
there should be some emphasis put on
community and coming together and just
how we can really expand when we're
together versus separate and apart it
was an incredible conversation she is so
lovely so make sure you pick up her book
becoming the one if you like this
episode please hit subscribe it shows us
that you appreciate our content and
what's being put out there and let us
know in the comments uh what you think
how you've become the one perhaps
hi
how are you i'm bummed this can't be in
person like last time i know it was kind
of nice i was i remember i was driving
home from eslin last time we saw each
other and
we got to do it in person but zoom will
have to do
right eslan that place that's has been
around for a really long time right yeah
it's so magical it's
it's a very rare unique energy that they
have going on there for sure have you
been back since then because that was
probably like
three two and a half years ago yeah it
was about yeah i was about two and a
half years ago it was right actually
before covid hit yeah yeah no we didn't
go back um i'd love to though i would
love to go back and
do workshops there and i'd also love to
facilitate workshops there it's got such
a beautiful energy
um the hot springs at night
are
mind-blowing you just naked and yeah you
can just be naked and you can just walk
down and i felt like i was in some
ancient like cathedral castle or
something everything of these long
cement pillars and you're overlooking
the ocean and wow how are you and ben
we're great yeah we're good we are very
busy we've been tending to our 10 acres
over the last year and
doing a lot of projects on the land and
does it
feel like therapy to you in some way or
is it just something you enjoy doing i
mean both nature is therapy definitely
it feels like every day we wake up and
we just look at each other and go is
this real like we live here this is our
life it's just so nice you know we're
tucked into the woods
um
and we have a lot of people who come and
visit a lot we have a lot of people who
come and do work parties with us
and help out and it just feels really
good we're just always
doing stuff outside and having fires at
night it feels like we're camping but we
have beds to go to
which is kind of my ideal life so right
i can't i mean i kind of have this idea
like i'd really love to go camping
camping and but you know only for maybe
two nights like there's only so much
time that you like have to you know go
without a shower and have a real
bathroom and a pill like a comfortable
you know temperature controlled
environment um but i i mean i laugh my
racing career felt like high-end camping
because there was a bus but you'd be
you'd be on in all these different
locations unfortunately not in nature
necessarily in the middle of a race
track but i kind of know that sort of
like pseudo-camping life yeah i feel
like that would feel really stressful
for me to be like camping on a racetrack
a little concrete jungle yeah you should
try the forest instead it's much better
and you can bathe in the creek or like a
lake and
there's a place nearby um
here it's about three hours we drive too
it's kind of out
there's not anything around there's just
ocean and there's this little creek type
river that runs through
the land then it goes into the ocean and
it's very cold but we'll go camp out
there for a few nights
yeah and
there's nothing out there
and you just go and get naked and bathe
in the creek every day and are you in
canada or are you in yeah we're in bc
yeah yeah
it's sort of like the ideal place to
be a nature person
yeah well i mean
even paul stamets would say the same
thing he bought property in bc and like
has all of his mushrooms and
like
tests things and has a bunch of property
and canada's stunning i actually was
just in montreal which i know is not
like bc and it's not nature necessarily
but canada is really pretty yeah you
should come visit i've never been to
montreal which is funny people would
think that you know canadians have been
all of the places but i've actually seen
most of canada because when we travel we
obviously we go
elsewhere
so i haven't really seen much of it but
yeah you should come visit you you'd
have fun
i will and or come to or do a workshop i
mean how would that work because you and
ben do such similar work like what does
a workshop look like for you guys if you
were do you do them do you do them
together yeah we haven't done any
actually in person together um
that i can recall
and we have a program called creating
conscious love which is
an online program so we're not actually
working directly with you
so we created that we actually created
that at the beginning of the pandemic
when we were like okay well what should
we do let's create this program together
um but for the most part he does a lot
of men's work and he runs men's groups
and does retreats so he goes off and
does that all over the place
those are in person and i am
only online at this point so
i don't actually do many workshops i do
a lot of
um digital programs
i've done one yeah and then i've i've
got some you know live events that i do
every once in a while through other
platforms
but i do feel the call over the next
couple of years now that the world is
opening up to
do a live event but we'll just have to
see how that goes there's so much
healing on so many different levels
happening
in the world and
one of the big ones obviously is sort of
you know how you show up for yourself in
your life and and and how that how
relationships
are such a magnifying glass for that and
that's why i think this book is so
brilliant i've said to you know talk to
a few people about it and
and especially about talking to you and
they're like man i need to read that
book
so
um i would imagine that on top of doing
the digital stuff you've been doing and
taking care of the land like writing a
book is like such a big project and um
okay so tell me like becoming the one is
your book tell me about it
was it intentional or did it feel like
you had to write this book like what was
the birth of this
yeah when i
excuse me when i first
was approached i was approached by
so many publishers
and
it felt like a sign for me that it was
time because i've always wanted to write
a book and i've always been a writer
but you know when do you have the time
to write a book it's like when do you
have time to have a baby like it's the
same there's no right time you know
because you you just have to do it i
just decided okay i'm gonna do this now
if just something felt right
and
i began
kind of flailing actually like i
i got a book deal and it was everything
was just so easy it almost like fell
into my lap but then
i felt really confronted with my own
self-doubt and i had a lot of resistance
and
i just had to work through that for a
while
and then eventually
ben and i we went to hawaii and we
stayed there for the winter and
i remember just sitting on the couch and
being like
i can't do this i'm gonna quit i'm just
gonna give my advance back i'm not a
writer like i was really hitting a wall
and i was crying and he just sat with me
and held space and was like okay well if
that's what you need to do and normally
he would push me but he just didn't and
then
he held space for me to do breath work
and that day
i sort of just moved through it and then
i began writing and i wrote the whole
first manuscript in four months and then
we spent about a year editing and
teasing it out and adding essence and
all of that and so it was an interesting
journey because
i saw a block that i didn't know was
there in me and so i had to work through
that and i think that's the beauty of
doing things that challenge us and that
push us push us to our edge
right because so often you hear like you
know you're gonna hit resistance when
you're on the precipice of doing
something big
um
and sometimes it's so deeply unconscious
that you don't even know it's there so i
had this really cool opportunity to to
get to the edge of quitting
and then to to move forward and to do it
and
and by the end of it i fell in love with
the process of writing this book
i felt like
i was deeply connecting with the people
reading it i was infusing essence in
every page
and it just felt so medicinal to work
with it
um
and at the end i i wrote you know an
outline for another manuscript because i
was just like this is what i love like i
want to write books this is what i want
to do
but it was yeah it was a really
enlightening process for me and i really
could not have done it without my team
like they pretty much handled everything
for a year
so that i could just write the book
because
at first i was like oh i'll just
write the book and do all the other
things
no
you need to just go on full-time jobs
no it's really an intense process so you
know i would be up all night sometimes
you know there were many many nights
where i was not going to bed with ben i
was staying up by the fire and editing
all night long
because that's when it felt
the most alive in me and so
yeah he really went through that journey
with me too
i bet yeah healing is i've found to be
very hard and it feels
it feels um there's a lot of pain
crying confusion
frustration loss all kinds of things i
wonder if we have to go through the fire
to come out the other side
and so you're talking about writing a
book to help people
become
the one in their relationship to write a
book and you you had to go through your
own fire to do that and i and i really
wonder are there any shortcuts yeah is
there anywhere that we can
heal grow and evolve
without having to go through the fire
well look i think
there is a bit of a yes and
to that for sure most of the time growth
comes through challenge
right right and and that's why
relationships are our greatest spiritual
growth container but they're also the
hardest
right so like if you go be a monk or a
nun like it's probably easier to become
enlightened because you don't have to
deal with any interpersonal drama
right you can
get there and you can have growth
experiences
and it can be gentler if you have
guidance if you have you know a core
connection to self
if you have people that you can trust
who can guide you
and sometimes it really is just going to
be hard and painful and stinky embracing
that is part of the medicine
to life remembering that it's actually
not it's not a bad thing
and it's actually even though it feels
uncomfortable
to get messy you know to lay it all out
on the table
it's actually a gift because we're sort
of de-armoring in those moments we're
really letting what's true come through
and we're also letting the people
closest to us see us
you know and and be there
so you know in my case like going
through the fire it was really hard but
it also created a lot of intimacy in my
partnership you know ben had an
opportunity to support me and see a
tenderness in me you know he said i've
never seen you in self-doubt like that
like it's because it that's not really
my
default you know like i'm typically
quite confident i just trust what i'm
doing i know
that i can do it i believe in myself and
so when this all came out it was very
new and he got to see this
tender part of me that he had never met
too
and so
sometimes if we can just look at it as a
gift and an opportunity for connection
then it can sort of take the pressure
off of it being this like really gross
ugly thing that you know we want to sort
of skip
now it gets a lot harder
when
we are in denial when we're in
resistance or when we're not open to
letting other people in to support us
where we are just sort of living
completely out of alignment
then the fire gets hotter and hotter
right because
the message isn't getting through
so we're just going to keep thrashing
around and so that's why i created this
book and that's why i created my
programs too it's not that you're not
going to still have to walk through the
fire but i can walk through it with you
and perhaps some of the things that i
share or some of the tools can help
lighten the load a little bit because
that's really all that we need right we
need those friends to walk with us to
not not only not feel alone in the
process but
also not feel alone in the pain of like
the magnitude of the pain because i
think what happens is that it gets
difficult for people and then they turn
away because they think they shouldn't
have to deal with something that bad
they shouldn't feel that way like oh
this must be wrong because i feel so
terrible the feeling is to go back
because it's safer and it's more
comfortable and it doesn't feel this bad
and bad must be bad what would you say
to someone that was in that space where
they
feel super lost or they feel very
confused or they feel really sad
like what would you what would you say
to them in that in that moment where
they might be willing to go backwards
yeah i mean i can i can really relate to
that first of all like i really
empathize with that experience because
i've been in those states where i'm in
so much pain that
i would rather go back to the comfort
zone even though i was miserable there
right like i i felt that way many many
years ago when i was in my own dark
night of the soul that
is really what this
book is a result of
right is all of that healing journey and
and the stuff that i went through to get
here
and so i can remember being in so much
pain that i i thought i might not make
it through
and it's really hard to tell yourself
that this makes sense or that this is
right and you know i i don't believe
that
you know the saying like you know
everything happens for a reason and like
it's perfect like sometimes
that's really not going to resonate when
there's like a serious tragedy or a
serious loss that you just can't make
sense of right
and
you're here now like this is what's
happening you know whatever has happened
has happened and so you can't take it
back
you're here and so your only choice is
to turn backward and perhaps collapse
into yourself
or
to expand and to just keep going and
even if that's really slow and gentle
which it should be
you know you can just keep unfolding
and
eventually
you see the light it's not this like
forever dark tunnel i always say past
pain is a passage not a prison like
you're not going to get stuck there and
i think one of the things that we fear
the most when we are in pain is that if
we let ourselves fully surrender to this
pain that we might get stuck there or
that we might get so deep that will be
locked in this depression forever and i
mean gosh i can relate to that you know
and so it's scary to let go
because we don't want to lose ourselves
but there is a bit of an ego death
happening in these moments too
right it's like can we let it go can we
just surrender to this can we let
ourselves feel it
what's behind that
and we really can shed a lot of layers
in those times of despair and
if we can call on those few people who
we love and trust who can hold us
through
and if we can seek solace in the
elements and in nature and find ways to
connect
then
we can feel a little more safe in the
process
are there some sort of signs of the ego
like when
it's coming in
and what it what it acts like what does
the ego sound like
how does it treat you how does it treat
the situation
so that people can be able to decipher
between
um something
outside of themselves like something
within them but something that is also
holding them back that they need to
um make a new piece with
yeah what i i relate to the ego in my
book is this sort of guard dog
but the guard dog is
not exactly protecting you against the
right things it's sort of just defending
you against everything and that's sort
of the ego's job is to be right and to
be to be alive just to survive it's a
survival mechanism right and so when we
are
in denial
when we're in resistance when we
are convinced that there's nothing this
has nothing to do with us and this is
all about other people there's nothing
here for us to learn and that you know
this is someone else's fault
sometimes that's the ego poking its head
in and and trying to guard us from the
vulnerability of
looking at our own shadow or looking at
our own role in the breakdown of the
relationship that we were in taking a
look at our patterns and what they
represent for us or what healing work
there is to do or what wound is being
opened we can sort of
recognize that
and say okay i see you know you're here
to protect me
and it's actually safe to go there i'm
gonna go there and we're gonna be okay
and just slowly make your way
through that
defensive armor and take a look at
you know what is the medicine here for
me and what am i here to learn
and
what's my role in all of this
and
it's tough to take responsibility for
our patterns and for the things that
have gone wrong in our lives but it's
also the most empowering thing to do
ever because as long as it's everybody
else's fault that means we have no power
we're helpless like everybody else is in
charge they're running the show but when
we step back and we say oh actually i do
play a crucial role in my story
and i'm not responsible for the actions
or the behaviors of other people or how
they chose to show up or respond but i
am responsible for me and what i've said
yes to and what i've engaged in and how
i've shown up and how i've communicated
where i've sort of fallen off track then
we can start to do the work of taking
our power back
and it can be confronting because when
we go through those those
passages we might feel overwhelmed with
guilt or
what if like what if i hadn't done this
differently oh i wish i hadn't known
this before why did it take me you know
until i was 40 or 50 or 70 to learn this
you know if only i had done xyz then i
would have you know had the relationship
kept my marriage not done that thing
but you know we're all just we're all
just walking the path in accordance to
our own timeline and we don't get to
control it and so i just say you know
it's never too late don't make yourself
feel bad
some people never get this opportunity
to wake up and so if you're in that now
it's a gift
you know and just really try to be
gentle with yourself because i see a lot
of people in that where they're they're
waking up and they're having these deep
realizations that are going to for sure
make their life better because they're
aware
and yet they're so focused on the fact
that it took them so long to get there
or you know wishing they could you know
rewind and
do things differently and i mean
that's a trap
i feel like
when people
wake up
that they feel like oh man this is the
worst this is hard this is it's making
things difficult when will this be over
and i'm like you know they feel like
they're just starting i think is the
general feeling that i get from people
when they get there is that they feel
like they're just starting and i'm like
you have no idea how far you are you've
spent your whole life in a prison of
your mind of thinking it's everybody
else's fault and when you start waking
up to the reality that you are
everywhere you go right there and you
have your own patterns you're actually
so much further along in the process
then uh then you realize
yeah it's so true sometimes you know i i
do these group coaching calls every once
in a while for participants of my
becoming the one my program and i get
people who come on and they're they're
revealing these really honest
and tender parts of themselves and
they're owning the ways that they have
sabotaged their love lives or that
they've fallen out of alignment or the
ways that they are responsible for
pushing people away
and they're just so honest
and it's breathtaking to witness and
then and then they go into this
self-doubt
i should have known this you know why
didn't i know this sooner and i'm just
like
i don't think you realize
how profound it is that you even are
willing to own
this about yourself
and that you see it because you're for
sure going to be a better person in
relationship next time like the way that
you show up is going to be
so much more loving and connected to
self because you're willing to own this
and that's all we can ask for right and
so i really do think we can get caught
in this trap of like never being enough
and never having
it right and not being perfectly healed
which is
never going to happen
we're never going to be perfect
it's as soon as you feel like you have
you know healed something
then you're going to enter into a
relationship or your relationship is
going to evolve and it's going to bring
new things
because that's just the nature of life
and that's like the cycle of nature too
it's to
bring change
right as the seasons change you get new
challenges you know in the summer you're
you're faced with you know how do i keep
my plants from burning and how do i you
know keep everything watered and
nobody's overheating and then and then
you know right when you get that figured
out then you move into winter and all of
a sudden it's like how do i
you know prevent my
you know everything from freezing and
you know how do i keep the water flowing
and so
that's nature and and that's what we are
right so it's like we're expecting
things to one day just
fall into place and everything's easy
because we've done our work
and things do get easier for sure they
get way more pleasurable they feel way
more harmonious big things don't
you know small things don't feel like
big things anymore yeah but there's
still going to be challenges along the
way
and it's just we learn how to work with
them through working with our own minds
and our own nervous systems i'm curious
about the healed part you know there's
an idea that we need to come into a
relationship when we've like found
ourselves and we're a healed person and
um as you said so simply it will never
be perfect what about not being healed
from a relationship and going into
another relationship even if that
relationship isn't the self it's someone
else is that a space that you can enter
a new relationship in uh or
should the focus be on working on
yourself until you've healed from that
relationship well look i think it's not
possible to
to fully heal from a past relationship
without
having new relationships and it doesn't
have to be romantic relationships but it
can even be friendships but
like we heal relationally
right because if we've had trust broken
or if we felt betrayed or if we've lost
hope how are we going to heal that on
our own like we need connection we need
other people so that we can remind
ourselves and reaffirm that love is safe
that connection is safe we can practice
communicating in a new way
we really do require relationship as
human beings
to evolve and heal our relational
challenges so that's the you know that's
the difference if you want to go and be
a monk and meditate on top of a mountain
and not do relationship then then sure
but if you're going to do relationship
work you need to be in relationship yeah
and also the thing is is like
most of us enter into relationships with
unhealed stuff from the past like i've
not yet met a person who doesn't have
something
that that isn't quite resolved or like
some
painful experience or memory that might
be lingering underneath the surface or
that might be causing some hesitancy to
let go or you know some time that they
felt betrayed or hurt and that's just
the nature of being human and taking
taking leaps and you know experimenting
in love
so
yeah i mean i would say
don't rush into a relationship when
you're feeling desperate
like if you've just gotten out of a
relationship and you're desperate not to
be alone and you're in this panic
because you need somebody yeah that's a
that's a red flag because the chances
are you're not going to attract somebody
who is super safe
right because you're going to be
attracting
just anyone you know you'll just say yes
to anyone you won't have the confidence
or the core to qualify but i i don't
recommend waiting until you've got it
all figured out to find a partner
because you'll be alone forever
thank god
what if we see someone outside of
ourselves a couple outside of ourselves
and we're really close to someone and we
can see that it's unhealthy how do we
address that yeah i mean it depends like
is it an abusive situation where your
friend is in trouble and you actually
need to support them in in getting safe
or are they just living out their human
patterns and figuring things out you can
be a sounding board and you can support
them and you can make reflections but
what i've learned along the way is that
even when i see that things are not
going to work or when i see a couple
that you know if they're obviously
not
bringing what what it takes to the table
to make it work there's something that
they have to learn in that relationship
before they're ready to let go and you
know i've seen this many times where
it's so obvious to me that this person
is not with the right partner
and
the relationship is clearly not good for
them and they even know it on some level
and yet they keep it going for a few
years and but then when they come out of
it it's like
that pattern really sunk in for them
they really saw it clearly and it's like
they needed to be
in that long enough to really see it
yeah and so
we have to let go and just let people
have their path because i know for
myself even
i've been in a relationship like that
where i've written about it in this book
where i
for years didn't even feel attracted to
this person but something kept me in
that relationship and that was because
it was such a karmic relationship for me
to see
all of my patterns clearly the way that
it erupted
and so as painful as it was i wouldn't
change it i wouldn't take it back
and we just have to remember you know
everybody's learning and all we can do
is love them yeah and that you have to
like it's back to the fire right it's
it's just that you hadn't felt enough
fire to really alchemize a pattern that
was unhealthy let's talk about
compatibility i'm very fascinated with
compatibility
my sister's laughing at me the other day
she's like you dated so many different
kinds of guys he's like whether they
look different act different like
they're so different and
i have a lot of curiosity around
compatibility and um and uh and what
what compatibility really looks like in
a relationship
and maybe also additionally from um an
attachment style perspective even
attachment style is funny because
if we're
more anxious we're definitely going to
attract someone who's more avoidant
you know it's just like anything about
that what do you mean
i know it's so funny i'm just like okay
you have to just surrender here like if
you are an anxious person
right now like if that's your pattern
you are most likely going to end up with
someone who is typically avoidant now
that's fine actually there's degrees of
attachment you know
styles
right some people are really far on the
end of the spectrum where they're
completely avoidant they're just going
to ghost you and not not show up but you
know everybody has some level of
ambivalence or avoidance or
whatever it may be you know and then you
know of course there's people who are
just secure
in pretty much every single couple and
person that i have ever seen or worked
with including my own relationship with
my husband there has been some level of
attachment to be repaired you know
there's some level of repair that's
needed
and so
i don't really resonate with this idea
that you need to go out and find
somebody who's secure
you see there's your attachment right
there
you're codependent sonny you're
definitely a codependent yeah
i love him
how cute is that his name is sunny too
dogs they're the best right they can be
i actually made that joke before i'm
like hey
i'm recovering codependent but i'm like
i just couldn't my last little bits i'm
just gonna leave it with me and my dog
ella yeah ella loves it i love it what
about like when you go deeper beyond the
attachment style into compatibility
how
can what are the signs that someone is
right for you and like there's chemistry
but then there's also the compatibility
element and um i'm just very curious as
i'm not sure i've executed that
correctly
well i mean it's going to be different
for everybody like what are your values
and you know really integrating the
attachment style thing the one
the one difference between somebody who
isn't going to be a match for you and is
is not whether or not they're avoided or
anxious is whether or not they're aware
and are they actually willing to lean
into it like are they actually willing
to work with you like do they want to
repair that in themselves you know
because
everybody's got something going on and
so if we're looking for that perfect
person out there who doesn't have any
stuff we're gonna be again we're gonna
be alone forever so it's really checking
for readiness like what's your readiness
score to do this you know like do you
want intimate connection
like do you want to move through that
resistance and that avoidance or that
anxiety where you actually can get to
wholeness and and secure connection
and if the answer is yes then you know
you've got a recipe for creating
conscious love together
and that's why ben and i named our
course that because we were like it's
about co-creation really
and you know compatibility is this
really interesting thing because we're
all so unique but it's what works for
you based on what you value
so i have a whole process in my book
around core values
because really core values are the
things that matter most to us that we
sort of build our life around we design
our life around either consciously or
unconsciously
and we select people based on those
values
but if we've prioritized just one or two
of those values like maybe we really
value sexual intimacy and passion
and we have all these other values as
well like integrity honesty respect you
know
reliability but we
over emphasize the sexual chemistry and
the and the passion
you know then we're disregarding some of
those other values and and then the
compatibility isn't there because they
don't actually have those other things
and so i take people through this
process of evaluating what's really
important to you you know what are the
nice to haves and what are the things
that you absolutely need
and then you can qualify you know where
do you stand on this what is your view
of relationship do we have the same
ideas of what a relationship looks like
and what it should look like
do we have the same ideas about conflict
because like one of the things that can
be an incompatibility is that
a person believes that conflict is bad
and then it shouldn't exist in a
relationship and then if there's
conflict you have to break up
and i see this actually quite often
where one person is like
i'm down to work through conflict with
my partner but my partner thinks that
because we have conflict that's a deal
breaker like
that everything should be easy they said
everything should be easy to me
i've heard that so many times and so
getting to know where this person stands
on those things to me that leads you to
more compatibility because
then you have the foundation
to
both live lives that are authentic to
you
and to connect on the important things
you know you don't have to have a
partner who does all the things with you
but like maybe
maybe you want somebody who
will go camping with you you know and
maybe you need somebody who is uh you
know into certain things but do they
have to be into all of the things no
we can't walk around with a little
checklist and be like oh well you're not
into this you know hobby of mine and so
therefore
you know see you later they say that
actually having some of your own unique
interests that you don't do with your
partner is actually really healthy
and
why do they say that why is that
important because we're individuals you
know and like we attract people who are
opposite to us and we attract people who
bring uniqueness into our lives like we
look for people who are different for us
for a reason even look look at your best
friend you know i don't know who your
best friend is but oh my god
from you yep i have basically
most of my best friends are opposite of
me meaning they're
very
watery emotional empathic sweet
listen you know and then i have a few
that are just like me it's wonderful
isn't it you know to have these
differences and to have these opposite
experiences with people and because we
get to a we get to experience some of
that within ourselves we draw people in
because we are drawn to
embodying that quality or that trait
ourselves
it brings this medicine into our lives
um and we get to grow and they get to
grow
and that's the beauty of being in
partnership with people who are
different too it's a better team
like i always give the example you know
in a company you don't hire five ceos
right because you don't need that you
need
different people in different roles
so when you look at your relationship
when your partner's opposite to you and
it's driving you crazy you can ask
yourself
what would happen if we joined forces
and
how would this make us the best team
ever
you know and and ben and i have found
that synergy too and like we're very
similar but we're also very different
and we've found a way to make that
the best team yeah you know and even you
know we see that working on our land
projects and things we both bring very
different skills and very different
mindsets
so it's such a gift once you learn how
to
step outside of this frame that
everybody needs to be like you and start
to appreciate
the gifts they're bringing
yeah well said and i feel like that's
sort of been described as you know
they're it's okay to be like someone
when you want to go camping or do
something like that but when you both
want to be in charge you're kind of like
looking at like a plug-in two plugs
instead of a plug in an outlet like it's
never gonna work when you're just the
same in every single category that you
should be different and also maybe this
is kind of where we could talk a little
bit about
the divine masculine and divine feminine
and
and how that
what those are
articulated and and how they express
um
and um and then how they just play into
a relationship and how that sort of
jigsaw puzzle fits together relationally
well we all i feel like we all embody
those energies within ourselves you know
you can call it yin and yang solar and
lunar energy
it's fire and water it's there's these
different polarities that we all have
within us and we all hold different
balances of those
and i don't really think that you know
one person is holding one pole and the
other person is holding one the other
pole always we're we're fluid in that
way that we can you know take turns and
sometimes this person is leading and
that person's leading and then we switch
um and there is this dance that's going
on within ourselves and within a
partnership all of the time
creating this this magical
flow essentially between two people and
within our own energies
um
and i have an interesting perspective on
it because i think we can become very
fixed on this idea that the feminine is
very
soft and flowy and you know wearing
pretty dresses and surrender and then
the masculine is like structure and you
know direction and leadership and all of
these things
um but i think we're all just a mix of
both
because i mean if you look at a mother
in in nature
would you rather come across a a male
bear or a mother bear in nature
i'd rather come across a male bear
oh really yes because a mother a mother
bear
will rip your throat out if you come
near her babies right like she is fierce
hey no
you think about cuddling with the mother
bears right
well i mean that's that's good it's good
good association to mother but the truth
is is like the mother is also very very
fierce and very protective and and and
has fight and fire you know and that's
this aspect of the feminine that isn't
often talked about
it's sort of like all given like this oh
but that's masculine right and so
sometimes i think it can be even helpful
to step out of that framework a little
bit into
looking at in a more elemental fashion
okay so in my in my book i break it down
in fire earth air and water
and which elements are we embodying the
most and which elements are we drawn to
um you know and in my in my partner you
know he is
he is quite what most people would call
masculine and very fiery and very
directed
um very focused you know and i can be
that too but i can also go into these
other polarities quite easily and then i
i can bring him into those places with
me you know more into the water
very earthy as well
and so
i think it can be really beautiful to
look at it from that perspective
instead of creating these again
checklists of what is masculine what is
feminine and then expecting our partner
to fit that and trying to contort
ourselves to be you know more feminine
in order to
attract a masculine partner does that
make sense sure yeah and and i also get
curious about just the you know the
balance of it within and so you know i
think traditionally the the
female is more feminine
dominant and the man is more masculine
dominant
um and do they have to fit like that in
a relationship or can you have
two feminines to two masculines like how
does that go together and i really
always ask selfishly because i know that
i have a lot of masculine energy and i
know i have a lot of dominance a lot of
leadership a lot of very direct um
and of course i have femininity in me
too but it doesn't doesn't always be
it's not always the strongest
but i don't also don't want a guy to be
super feminine right so like how does
that work in relate relationally yeah
well it doesn't matter if you're you
know if you're two women in a
relationship two men in a relationship
man and a woman in relationship what
you'll notice is that there's always
polarity
so there's always this opposite thing
going on right there's these unique
energies there's the yin and yang
there's the feminine masculine there's
the solar and the lunar energy
because we are wired to attract
something that's different you know
uh
and
i can relate to you you know i have a
lot of fire as well i think we're
similar in that way i'm very much you
know in a leadership
position in my life
i know where i'm going
and i find it really nice in my
partnership to be able to
kind of let go and let my partner sort
of hold that pull for me sometimes
it's not forced you know it's not
inauthentic i'm not like oh i'm gonna
pretend to not know things so that you
can feel powerful i just genuinely see
how his mind works differently than mine
and he has a certain
way of doing things that
i wouldn't have thought of
because i approached most things from
feeling and how they look and feel and
he approaches most things from
if they make sense and if they work
efficiently
you know and so it's just this thing
where you know we have to learn where to
utilize our energy and how
so
for example with ben and i we're both
strong leaders we both have
strong minds we both know who we are and
what we want
and so what we found is that if we
are both bringing that energy intensely
we can accidentally try to lead each
other in ways that we don't need to be
led
so we had to make an agreement like one
of our wedding vows was that we would
learn how to direct our leadership
energy out into our communities
together rather than toward each other
so that you know we can sort of stay in
our own lane so to speak yeah because
you know one of the things that's just
natural for us is to just
try to help each other
do something or to tell each other you
know how to do the thing or what to do
next and it's not that either of us
thinks the other person is dumb or
doesn't know how to do it it's just so
natural for us to lead and so we have to
catch ourselves and like right yeah
you've got it you know
and and so then we we learn how to
direct that energy when we're both in
our fire and our leadership energy you
know into something else like a project
or our own businesses you know our work
and then when we come together
we do naturally fall into a polarity
where i
tend to hold a different pole than he
does
but then through that we can actually
bring each other into each other's
worlds and that's the point is not to
like
just hold the opposite but it's actually
to invite each other into these
different energies and to be able to
embody them together
and so i can bring him into a more
feeling space and bite him into his
heart
and we can drop into that space together
so it is about us also being willing to
explore in the emotional realms
well it sounds like vulnerability like
it just made sounds like you have to be
vulnerable and you know maybe that's
another kind of hot topic word where
maybe give me your perspective on what
vulnerability looks like
well there's there's performative
vulnerability that we see a lot on
social media right where we see
i'm being vulnerable so that i can get
likes
um i'm being vulnerable so that
i can
you know just tell a story
or i'm being vulnerable to really
authentically share and reveal myself
because this is what feels true for me
now are those first ones really
vulnerability though if they're done
with an agenda is that actually
vulnerability well there's a thing is a
lot of times we think that it is and and
they're it's not that it's completely
authentic
you know there's a lot of people who you
know there is a performative aspect
going on but there they feel that
they're being
very vulnerable but the depth that they
could go to perhaps if they were to you
know keep that process sacred to
themselves for a little longer and
actually work with it or you know share
it intimately with a friend or a partner
behind closed doors rather than on
social media would likely give them a
deeper sense of connection and intimacy
than what they're gonna get when they
you know do it online and they you know
they have an emotional experience and
then they instantly post about it or
share about it and i i talk about this a
lot in my my programs too around the
principle of containment and really
knowing you know when it's time to share
and when it's time to
hold on to that what does vulnerability
feel like to you
is there a visceral feeling is there a
way to describe it that's a really great
question everybody will be be different
in how they feel it in their bodies so
you can sort of tune in when you're
experiencing
vulnerability and notice you know where
in my body am i feeling this am i
feeling open am i feeling light am i
feeling tension for some of us
on the precipice of feeling
vulnerability we might actually feel
afraid
yeah it's
a big risk right to reveal ourselves and
so sometimes it's not gonna feel
relieving it's gonna feel almost like a
holy [ __ ] what am i doing you know and
and we might even have a feeling of a
shield coming up or a defensiveness
coming up and then we have to be with
that
and then slowly reveal
and that's why you know sharing your
vulnerability in safe places with people
who you know you can trust
is the best way to practice because it
isn't easy when many of us have learned
that our vulnerability will be used
against us
or our vulnerability wasn't well
received you know or we we were with
people who were emotionally out of tune
with us when we were young
and then it's we've been trained to
guard and to protect
so yeah it can feel like a whole range
of things but ultimately
one of the things that we don't expect
is the vulnerability hangover
which is we're first practicing
vulnerability and we
and we
reveal something really honest or really
you know tender about ourselves we might
feel the next day we might feel this
vulnerability hangover we're like oh
gosh like why did i say that
you know we're
we're second guessing ourselves and
we're like oh i shouldn't have said that
or maybe i should have kept that secret
or you know and that's just like the
natural process of learning how to to
reveal ourselves and be more authentic
in relationship
yeah i have i have found that
that for me
vulnerability always does feel a little
bit um scary like you feel like oh no
should i shouldn't i should i say this
should i post this should i do that
and there and i also i don't know this
is a little bit of just like an offside
thought but i was i feel like there's um
like in this world of energy that we all
are and everything is i feel like
there's a
frequency with vulnerability that
resonates with people
um and that's why it connects people for
sure i mean so many of us feel like
we're alone in our process what we're
going through is
really different than what anyone else
is going through and so we feel alone
and there's just something so nice about
seeing other people be honest
so as much as as much as i say you know
there's performative vulnerability i'm
not saying you should never post about
what you're going through or your
emotional process on social media i'm
simply saying no do you need to share it
right in the moment right like when we
share something immediately we sort of
we deflate the energy and we sort of
take away from getting that that
medicine that might be trying to happen
within us
and so it's just about giving it time
until there's not as much charge and so
that you know whether you receive
positive or negative feedback it doesn't
actually impact you if you share
something when you're in a really
vulnerable state and then people react
negatively especially not serving you in
your growth
it's taking away from it and so it's
also a way to honor your process
and it's so beautiful when people are
willing to show up you know i see this a
lot in the motherhood space too where
you know moms come out and they share
these really intimate vulnerable parts
of their reality and it gives other
people permission and it helps them know
that you know
that person isn't perfect and no
nobody's life is perfect and actually my
struggles are okay and we all need that
and and it's even more beautiful when
it's happening in real life in our
communities like on the ground
is it possible to sort of articulate the
steps in which you go about that process
um in
going about the process of healing your
relationship patterns or yeah and
becoming the one i mean ultimately like
that couldn't be there couldn't be
what is it ramdas says like the the best
work i can i'm not gonna get it right
but it's basically the best thing i can
do for you is to work on me and the best
thing you can do for me is to work on
you like it's not necessarily always
about working together it's about doing
your own individual work to
become the one and and and so i'm just
curious if there's a a path
and and steps in which
people can um
you know get it in their head that there
is a process to this and what does it
look like nobody that doesn't want to be
the one like you owe it like if you were
to say hey would you like to outsource
your happiness to someone else and that
sort of like comes and goes or would you
like to would you like to be happy all
the time pretty much
yes there'll be a few challenges along
the way but you'll always be able to
rely on yourself you don't you don't
have to worry about relying on someone
else i think everyone would want that
everyone would want that stability
within themselves yeah and i mean it's
not even so much about
not relying on people because that's we
have to rely on people otherwise we
won't survive like i mean we could but
it won't be that enjoyable right but
it's about do you feel whole and secure
within yourself or do you need
another person to come in and complete
you because when you come a relationship
from that perspective as you were saying
it's like
how far can we really get together when
we're leeching energy off of each other
instead of co-creating this reciprocal
energy that fuels us to be of service in
the world so in the book i just opened
it up and you know in the contents we
break it down into five
parts
so part one is reclaim your relationship
to self so we're working on
really
understanding our relationship to
ourself coming home
to our body's wisdom connecting with our
inner child and then in part two it's
all about healing your past and so we're
really looking at our abandonment
wounding our relationship to our mother
father
reclaiming divine mother and father
energy and working through forgiveness
on any unhealed relationships
and then there's part three which is
exploring your relationship patterns and
that's all about really getting clear on
what are those patterns in you and where
do they come from
what are the things that you're bringing
into the equation
and
where have you ignored the signs of red
flags in your life
and what do green flags even look like
what does a healthy relationship look
like yeah and then we move into part
four which is all about realigning to
your truth so that's where we look at
our boundaries that's where we look at
our core values that's where we learn to
examine our expectations
and you know what are the things that we
expect from our relationship and what's
healthy to actually expect versus what's
a fantasy mm-hmm
and then part five is you know getting
what you want in relationship and that's
where we talk about creating a conscious
relationship and actually creating a
love map
based on everything that you've learned
about yourself for what you want your
relationships to look like and what you
want your relationship to self to look
like
and
many people create these beautiful maps
some of they're so creative um they're
very visual and people put them on their
altars
you actually do a map yourself yeah and
and there's a few examples in the book
and um i think i'm going to put some
online as well for people to see but
they're just
a culmination of the values and the
traits and the qualities and the in the
the ways of being that we want to see in
our lives and in our relationships um
all taken from
what we've learned about ourselves along
the way in the program and
and so it all kind of comes together in
the end
to give you a clear picture of you know
what it is that you stand for
what's the point of a relationship
what a great question what do you first
what do you think the point of
relationship is
i think that
when
two people can
be vulnerable and be honest and be
themselves i think that two is always
better than one and i think you can
accomplish more i think that if you can
be yourself you will then um
i think your energies multiply
and you can make a bigger impact and you
can
raise your frequency to the point where
you feel more joy it's easy enough to be
loved when you're showing all the best
stuff but like the feeling of being
loved when you show the worst stuff
there can't be a greater feeling that
someone still chooses you and someone is
still
someone wants someone like that that's
willing to show up to do the work they
almost love you more for the effort that
you put into the work than it is when
it's easy and good um so i think that
the point of relationships is to see
yourself because we're always attracting
that other person to mirror us um
we don't i don't think that that's a
common
common thing that people would know that
but i i really feel that that's the
truth of our our whole reality is
um
to see us to see ourselves and there's
nothing more intense than a relationship
because it's so sensitive and personal
and we take offense to so much because
it's really our most vulnerable place
um so it's like the biggest mirror and
the most intense mirror it's like a
magnifying glass and um instead of a
mirror yeah so i think it's to see
ourselves and then to then um
and to uh then be able to expand that
energy i think on a macro level if we
could
improve this balance of the the
masculine and feminine or men and women
or the this sort of
um
even called patriarchal sort of you know
history that we've been in or seemingly
been in
i think
that when each can recognize the other
for the good yeah we just expand greatly
absolutely yeah i love everything that
you said and i really resonate with that
i think it's a really beautiful way to
look at relationship and i i see it in a
similar way you know relationship isn't
there to make us whole or to complete us
but it is there to help us grow and to
thrive
you know and when two people come
together from a place of wholeness and a
willingness to
you know like we said navigate the hard
times but also
really elevate each other's joy and
celebrate each other
that can be a really beautiful thing and
in my book i talk about the difference
between
a vacuum relationship and a power grid
relationship
you think about a vacuum like a vacuum
just sucks everything up right it's like
taking all the energy and what if the
vacuum spits something back out you
don't want it
so it just doesn't give back that's the
kind of relationship where all of the
energy it's all about taking
and anything you do get back you don't
you don't really want but when you have
a power grid relationship when you're
reciprocating and there is this energy
redistribution between you and it's just
constantly creating more energy because
there's an abundance flowing between you
then all of a sudden you have energy to
give outward to your communities to your
projects to the things that you love and
you're making the world a better place
because your home and your relationship
is a safe and loving place to be
and we know that that is the foundation
that we all need and if we look at the
reason why so much of our world is in
chaos and then we look at what those
people's family lives were like we
learned that you know when we didn't
feel loved or respected or seen or
understood
it makes it very hard to be
a healthy person
as an adult there's a lot for us to work
through
and so if we can create that beauty and
that paradise within our own homes the
world will be a better place
so you know relationship should be about
co-creating joy and peace and happiness
and love
and it requires work to get there
but you know once you do the work and
you start to learn how to be whole in
yourself and have confidence and trust
yourself and trust the other person's
intentions and trust in love
it doesn't always have to be hard and it
doesn't have to be tumultuous you'll go
through a power struggle phase but
eventually you get to a place where
things are mostly harmonious our world
is in such chaos and there's such
transition happening there's so many
things that have happened in the last
couple of years and maybe you could give
me your perspective on on sort of a
macro perspective
of what's happening on the planet and
then maybe like a best-case scenario of
our of of how we come out of this better
um more harmonious um at a higher
frequency
and um leading to a better better
reality for all of us
yeah i mean i don't have the answers but
what i do know is that right now we're
in a heightened state of polarization
where we are not listening to each other
we're not really accepting each other's
differences
there is a lot of
conflict
and a lot of you know needing to be
right and holding on to a position about
what we believe to be true and
differences are what make the world go
round and if we could really see
through different lenses and really drop
into our hearts we would realize that
that's actually okay
you know it's okay to have different
perspectives
so right now it's been a very
interesting few years you know there's
been just like a lot of
tension and chaos and also a lot of
focus on
you know
getting authority figures and systems to
fix things for us and
the truth is is that you know i see
politics as sort of like a dead end
because
from what i've seen is
it doesn't matter who you vote for or
what party you stand for what person
promises to make changes
that just never happens you know because
i i think most people who step into
politics maybe they think they're going
to make a difference and they get into
the system and they find out they're
just there's a bobble head like they're
just a placeholder
for something that's already running on
its own and they just need a face that's
how i feel you know some people might
not like that i think that or that i say
that but that's what i believe
and so it's not that i don't vote or
that i don't you know hold positions but
i also i can find
a perspective that that resonates within
most different
parties or perspectives you know i don't
hold any one position because i can see
where different people are coming from
and i think the most powerful thing that
we can do is to work on ourselves and
within our communities and in our
families and really prioritize that
community-based healing and creating
these pockets of change within our own
little world
yes and that ripples out and it seems
like that's the thing that we can do
now you know and so
i would love to see us
go back a little bit toward the
community-based
practices where you know we are more
communal
which is what i experience here where i
live where you know everybody knows
everybody and you you literally know
your neighbors and they know everyone in
town and every contractor on the island
has you know been to your house before
and
um you know you just help each other out
and you get your eggs from your neighbor
and you bring each other food and
it's just
that to me is that's living life you
know and that's really getting back to
to nature and what we're meant here for
we're meant to be in connection and so
the online world is very distorted it's
true it's not it's like oddly connected
but disconnected emotional disconnected
in a great way too
yeah it's it is and it's um
it's getting
kind of scary to me anyways i mean i was
i was i was reading an article the other
day about some things that are happening
in in the metaverse and it really scared
me just for our future generations and i
i'm pretty committed to
you know when i have children to raising
them in a way that they feel really
connected to nature so that
um they don't feel like their world is
outside of them so much
because that's really where we're going
now you know is this
we're creating this virtual world and
we're forgetting that we live in the
world already yeah that's so good we're
really
we're one generation away from fixing
the problems if everyone raised their
children
to
you know look inside themselves to
become the one to connect with nature to
take care of nature i think there should
be a big emphasis on that and so
yeah doing the right thing girl thanks
love been so nice to chat with you you
too you too i'm so proud of you and this
book is so cool i can't wait to read it
thanks yeah i'm excited for you to get
your hands on i'll send you a copy and
yeah it's really nice to see all of the
people they're tagging me with their
book and seeing the reviews already come
in and it's just
a lot of people are buying this book for
their friends and their sisters and
their moms and i'm just like yes this is
what i wanted is it just to feel like
something that they want to share you
know well i've already got people saying
that they should probably read the book
yeah
based on like yeah i do need to become
the one instead of seeking it outside of
myself and i think it's an incredible
lesson and i'm really grateful for you
thanks love well it was great chatting
with you and i hope i see you in person
sometime soon thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button